in my 16 years on this earth in my 16
years on this I'm I hate you for making
me say this the fate of Jumanji is in
your hands the goal for you I'll recite
and verse return the jewel and lift the
curse
cheerio off you go
good alright guys here we are we are in
the jungle we are deep in the jungle
I believe I'm discovering new land new
territories you can see this as real as
it gets I have had no water no food I've
been catching fish with my bare hands
and I do not even recognize they have
three heads I am hallucinating out here
I have had zero contact with the outside
world and I think hey hey hey yes we
just keep the head on me dude and see
that like I was saying I'm discovering
new land
welcome to Jumanji you ruined a shot son
of a [ __ ] you're ruining production
just gotta shut down here on the set of
Jumanji it's not cuz of weather not
because of the crazy environment that
was shooting in because Jack Black
needed to finish his rice Jack you good
yeah no Jack said I'm not shooting [ __ ]
so I finished my damn rice ain't that
right jack that's right Jack said you
can kiss my ass
production can wait you okay Jack big
guy ready shoot coming out the jungles
of Jumanji are amazing but you got to be
careful cuz a lot of mosquitoes and the
Skeets come out at night
he's come at night the skis go at night
miss Keats come out at night the skids
come out
all right it's 3:00 a.m. on set we just
wrapped here on Jumanji these fans right
here I got the greatest fans in the
world they have literally been waiting
out here somewhere
I don't know 9 12 hours or something
like that here they all right here all
right all right good to meet you good
night
you